(bouncy, acoustic strumming)
- We got Valentine's Day comin' up.
I want to be the best
boyfriend ever this year.
I'm thinking quiet night at home,
make her favorite meal,
cuddle up next to the fireplace.
- Good for you.
That sounds really simple.
You know what I'm gonna do?
I'm planning a romantic picnic in the park
followed by ice skating.
- Oh, I used to love ice skating
back when I was like five.
You know what I'm gonna do?
Her favorite band's gonna
be in town that weekend.
I think I'll get tickets to the show,
and then afterwards get a couple's massage
performed by the band.
- Oh wow.
I hope the band washes
their hands after the show.
You know what I'm gonna do?
I'm renting a cabin in the mountains
so we can go skiing together on snow
I made with a snow machine.
- I really hope she
doesn't get frost bite.
You know what I'm going to do?
We're gonna go to the San Diego Zoo,
take pictures with all the animals.
She loves animals.
And then we're gonna set 'em all free.
- Oh my goodness.
That sounds really dangerous.
You know what I'm gonna do?
I'm renting a hot air balloon
so we can go ballooning over the Alps
while projecting her
favorite movie on the clouds.
- Well I hope she doesn't get
hit in the face with a bird.
You know what I'm gonna do?
(low chanting, bouncy music)
I'm gonna propose.
- God dammit!
(ringing)
- Congratulations.
You've won the best boyfriend award.
(laughing)
- Ye-he-hah!
Suck it sucka!
(bouncy electronic jazz music)
(creaking)